like there's some people that i feel
like [__] going on with that
i feel like others shouldn't [__] with
mm-hmm
right
t.i for one
hey yo till they figure that out you
know i ain't with that kind of [__] are
you talking about the allegations about
straight up like with the women yeah and
then it's going to be interesting to see
that what comes of this y'all i mean me
personally i can't front i know t.i i'm
a t.i fan listening to tr music right
i hope he's innocent of this [__]
but i hope i really really hope
that he's innocent of that
right
but it's some things that they went on
in this man's life that a lot of people
didn't overlook too keeping it real
[__] ain't crazy
it's a lot of [__] been to the
feds [__] understand that 12
months a day kick out
you know what i'm saying you know and
things are done differently these days
so it's like you know it's a lot of
things that they went on that i look at
certain people and say but i understand
it right you know it may be out of
genuine love as a brother maybe some
business going on it may be that they
see it different than me
right you know and vice versa so i'm
going to understand
my side of it too as well